NARRATOR: Before another day
comes to an end on Oak Island,
brothers Rick and Marty Lagina
and their partner Craig Tester
gather in the war room with
other members of their team
for a much anticipated meeting.
Guys, this is the part
of the war room meetings
I really like.
We've got some
information, some results
coming in on dendrochronology.
It's specific, it's to the wood
we took out of Smith's Cove.
I believe we sent samples
of the U-shaped structure,
the L-shaped structure,
some of the walls that
were more dimensional lumber.
So Professor Colin Laroque with
the University of Saskatchewan
has analyzed everything.
And Jack, he's standing by.
Can you get him
up on the screen?
Sure.
RICK LAGINA: Colin!
How are you, sir?
- Good.
How are you guys?
Good, thank you.
We're looking forward
to the results.
MAN: That's quite
a significant wall.
This is totally undiscovered.
NARRATOR: Over the
past three months
the Oak Island
team has unearthed
numerous mysterious
wooden structures
buried as much as 10
feet beneath the seabed
at Smith's Cove.
In addition to finding the U
and L-shaped structures first
discovered by Dan
Blankenship in the 1970s,
the team uncovered the
remains of a massive slipway
or shipping ramp.
With each new discovery,
the Oak Island team
extracted wood samples
for scientific testing
in the hopes of obtaining
reliable dates as to when
they were constructed.
These samples were then sent to
Dr. Colin Laroque, a professor
of dendrochronology
and climate science
at the University
of Saskatchewan.
CRAIG TESTER: Why don't you
go through sample by sample
and give me the date?
COLIN LAROQUE: OK.
Sample 7, That was one of
our more confident samples.
CRAIG TESTER: Sample
number 7 is the slipway.
It's the north arm
on the east end.
So the slipway.
It was, we believe, red spruce.
It's reminiscent to
some of the samples
we did in other
areas of Halifax.
We had a fairly strong
date on and that's 1771.
Wow.
Predates the money pit.
Yep.
Wow.
That's really cool.
Yeah.
The two that
are coming up next
are actually some of
the biggest samples.
Sample 8 and sample
9, we call them.
CRAIG TESTER: Sample number 8
is the U-shaped shaped structure
and sample number
9 is another piece
of the U-shaped structure.
So for both
samples we had 1769.
Wow.
This is quite impressive.
I mean, that's huge.
Yeah.
We could pretty much be sure
that all that work in Smith's
Cove occurred in about 1770.
That's pretty amazing.
Yeah.
Well, if we can
find more of that wood
from the money pit that
dates to that same era then
we'll have a bullseye.
Yes.
And it ties in.
Yeah.
Hey, Colin.
How accurate of a
list do you have
that you can compare it to?
Right.
The one red spruce chronology
that we were using, which
is about a 550-year-old
tree that is still growing,
and it matches with that.
So something like sample
8 we're at probably 99.999
sure that it sort of
ends in that 1770 time.
Wow.
This is big.
Oh yeah.
In these kind of things they
tend to answer one question
and raise two or three others.
What a shock that is.
[laughter]
COLIN LAROQUE: I think so.
Great work.
I love the 99.99.
We don't we don't get
that ever, so thanks
for being in on the quest.
You're welcome.
All right, Colin.
Thank you very much.
We will be in touch,
really appreciate it.
Excellent report, thank you.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
Take care guys.
I believe that
we have just found
conclusive proof that not
everything we're finding
is searcher, OK?
Yeah.
For me this is the biggest
thing that's happened
since we started this quest.
It's amazing.
I was about to say
direct, turned to him
and say, look, it's time
to turn this island over
from the archaeologists to
the psychiatrists because--
[chuckles]
The first time I heard--
--because this isn't
making any sense.
And then at the 11th
hour we find out
something very significant
happened here 25 to 30 years
prior to the discovery
of the money pit,
and it's in Smith's Cove.
To me that's gigantic.
Well, I have to say I'm
impressed with this.
I'm happy that
you're impressed.
I am impressed!
Let's go.
OK.